vous avez dit que hitler c'est
pratiquement toujours trompés sur le
plan stratégique
où est-il bon en revanche sur le plan de
la tactique militaire par exemple alors
tactiquement il n'y a pas que la
formation as quand même qu'un caporal de
la première guerre mondiale
mais il a il a un sens assez sûr au
niveau opérationnel
je pense que c'est dicté par un certain
nombre d'impératifs politique chez lui
vous savez en 1939 quand la france et
l'angleterre déclarent la guerre à
l'allemagne
les généraux allemands sont terrorisés
sent pas sûr du tout qu'ils vont pouvoir
ceux qui vont pouvoir battre l'armée
française
d'autant plus qu'il rentre dans la
guerre avec le vieux planches les fans
de 1914
j'exagère à peine mais le plan originel
il est de d'envahir la part la belgique
passé par la belgique est ensuite foncé
sur paris par le nord c'est le plan
qu'avait utilisé ce qu'il fait en 1914
ce plan ne plaît pas à hitler pourquoi
il ne plaît pas hitler
pourquoi il est en quête est en
recherche d'autres choses parce que
c'est un plan il en est certains qu'ils
amènent dans une guerre longue
une guerre d'attrition hitler c'est
l'homme qui est capable de prendre tous
les risques
parce qu'il veut toujours aller vite il
veut battre l'adversaire le plus vite et
au moindre coût
c'est la raison pour laquelle lorsque ce
général von manstein qui commande un
simple qui n'est pas du tout dans les
premiers rangs de l'armée allemande à
cette époque là il est même en en semi
disgrâce depuis la fin 38 quand ce
général fondement de stein lui amène ce
fameux plan jona qui consiste à prendre
une option incroyable passer par les
ardennes faire passer par les ardennes
100000 véhicules
cette division panzer le meilleur de
l'armée allemande pour crever le front
français là où personne ne l'attend et
filé directement vers la vers la manche
hitler voit le voit le bon dieu venir à
lui c'est exactement ce qu'ils cherchent
ça répond à ces à ses attentes
politiques et j'ajouterais même
qu'aujourd'hui on sait on à plusieurs
déclarations que cette idée au départ
c'est aussi celle d'hitler
avant même qu'elle laisse chez bernstein
hitler là il a alors il la développe pas
sur un sur une carte
mais il aimait cette hypothèse devant
ces généraux vous êtes sûr que c'est pas
que c'est pas plutôt par les ardennes il
faudrait passer
donc il a un il a un sens opérationnel
ah oui c'est incontestable il a sa
principale qualité c'est de devoir les
défauts de ses adversaires de savoir où
il faut les frapper
c'est également usage de la surprise de
la vitesse ça c'est quelque chose qui
l'a accompagné dans sa carrière
politique et qui va continuer à
l'accompagner par la suite il n'empêche
que si globalement sur une feuille de
papier et vous mettez dans la colonne
vous faites une colonne des plus et une
colonne des moins
il est certain que globalement hitler
n'a pas rendu que des services à l'armée
allemande
il s'en fout redoutent beaucoup
[Musique]